後日肇社長ですアンナとプーでんですもうさぁくるんですけど
5万円近く第6弾いきなりなんですけどやろうと思います
第1弾日目のいって代理何いう行カード100万円第3弾
遊園地貸切大ようなうまい棒第5弾甘いも配ったやつそして第6弾になったわけなん
ですけども
あの本当にこれやる予定がなくて本当に今日突然やりました玉田な京都家の近くの
ショッピングモールいって
自転車買おうと思って400乗っちゃに見てたんですけどそしたら外を見ると
なにあれなにあれというぐらいちょっと不思議な自転車が置いてありまして
てか自転車かどうかも怪しいだったんで乗ってる人に位置と聞いてみたらやっぱり自転
車ということで実際にちょっと塗らせていただきました
おおすごい変えるダメ
やばいよメカ監視マシンん
信じたいなぁ
[音楽]
何コレだ分
このまま借りパクします惚れましたちょっとまたまたねその後自転車大変なんじゃない
ジャンアレジ田さんの星そう私の僕もネットですがあの事例さんなんか色々調べて
リーダーを見たら約120万円でした
帰るそれでも本当に欲しくなりましてその人もその子会社を振ってるらしいんでこれ
もうこれ買うしかねーなっていうわけで実は教派取れちゃったんですけど今家に来て
おります
[音楽]
ん
4日
で何か話を聞くと買ってから2ヶ月作るのに2カ月かかるって聞いたんですけども
んかすごいいい人ですごい僕が塗りたそうにしすぎてて
その方がなんとブーブー旅中なんですけど今
今撮ってその自転車 oo
[拍手]
早速まで切れば即刻わけで今日たまたま
ショッピングモールに行ったらやりましたあっよろしくお願いですね
すげー形の税車に乗ってたんですよねっ
はっはっはっ曲一人てみてくださいねなんかいろいろ話を聞きすると
近未来の前座を開発されているということで
はいすごい乗り物でまぁ健康にもいいし
環境にもいいし
でまぁ快適ですごい軽くてスピードも出るし渋滞もらえ
車のいろんな課題を解決できる乗り物だと思ってるんですこれからもうちょっと日本の
方1ナースちっちゃい車体のものを作って電動にしてなんとか涼しい4すればみんなに
乗ってもらえるブラシに乗るものになるんじゃないかなと思ってる
これをぜひ日本広めたいなぁと思っ
曲げせてくださいいやもうなんかほんとパッと見で火爪ぼれしちゃって琢磨になった
せると思って来た来たって思ったんですけど作るのに3ヶ月くらいかかるって聞いて2
ヶ月かぁ
思っていたところその今乗ってた本体をもらえることになりましたけどね
ございますよね旅してたんですよねそうですね
ベロモービルは日本中に広めるという日本全国テストライブツアー
ん
今日16日名だったんですけど僕のせいで度2番だよぴえいえもう帰りだったんで全然
直ってつだから金額の方あ津波に
今全国ツアー中で10%を八幡ですが8番
もう一応今乗ってたん2苦痛ばさと重厚者ということなのでまあまあと10万円であっ
た第たり
たし
898万からキロ素材集たつまんでいいんですかねはい
よろしくね頑張ってください
現金100万円もが良かったご来客100万円の
奇妙な音ず買ってみたねー
ございますそれじゃあ当該消します
ていた
プラズマで撮るんですな学ばずでも素敵
安くしてもらって98万円でございますさせていただきまさい
あれ
ございましたほんと何か運命的な芸をした
なかなか持って大切に
set 目いただけますはい
がとうございます
ましたん
あとで骨だて2両首相を送っていただけると
突然の100万円規格品未来の自転車買ってみましたーーー
あーなんかがすごいです何かがこれがでハンドルちゃんのハンドルで分ことブレーキに
なってて
で多くにあるがペダルですられないと思う
ないとも付きますこの曲がる時を取らんと思ってます it 化で100万円の自転車
でございますもう見た瞬間見た目一目惚れしちゃって本当にいい人でよかったらそれっ
持ち歩いてみ
ああああああ
いろんな意味でやばいよ時で今のところもこれに乗っているのはどうやら世界で僕だけ
みたいでございます初の購入したらしいんで早速近未来の100万円自転車乗ってみ
ましょう
じゃ出てきます
me
パパッ
voodoo ん
[音楽]
amaran
前から見ると
a
う払わなきゃで結構早いんだねいやあのどうやら髪切るぐらいまでのせず気になったん
ですね
この法的によると軽車両なんですっっ
どこでもわかっていらっしゃる
めっちゃいいと思いますかねうんできる人がいいじゃないですよ確かに
ん
ありません
図鑑強かっこぃーへどうもー
pip 早いっ
[音楽]
俺じゃないよ
関取るぜ
持っていた
おっ
持った
me
teame
car
ああっあああっ